l'objectif c'est d'arriver à sa
l'arrivée et faire du boudin voilà on va
essayer d'arriver jusque là alors c'est
du bout des doigts
alors ça c'est du sang coisel carla
l'âme sensible quoi céder 100 gr non pas
du tout nos noces et d'ognoas ne dis pas
ça tombe bien c'est pas grave
bon d'accord la laser alors vous voyez
ici vous avez donc du sens ici vous avez
du boyau s'agit du boyau si le show de
monde pour cent de tous alors le vote
petit travail va consister à trouver une
extrémité tenez je vous le donne tout et
de traduire sa carla bruni en
exclusivité fait du boudin
on a fait une bonne charcutière pour le
moment donc jeu consiste à considérer
qui m'arrivait
maintenant la moiteur remplir le boyau
avec le sens des intérêts du bout du
bout là je suis en train de faire du
boudin voilà et est-ce que vous avez
déjà fait du boudin jamais jamais je
n'ai pas du tout que c'était aussi est
ce que vous vous y tenir seule seconde
avant de bientôt des lacs normal parce
que la wii je n'aime pas je vais essayer
de nous parce qu'on va pouvoir pendant
deux heures on va essayer d'en faire un
déjà voilà fait un bouddha ça fait très
bien
alors là maintenant il faudrait vous
fait glisser moi c'est un non non non
non non qu'êtes vous descendez pas
encore doucement doucement nous c'est
fragile c'est du boyau ni attendait ça
il faut pas qu'il y ait de l'air de bien
mais tu es déjà formés sur lui si vous
voulez remettre un petit foot sein d'un
veto du sang il est né voilà
ça me tue
mayotte c'est parti on va pouvoir
l'arrêter là mais savoir frais du boudin
je récupère ça ça peut se récupérer de
loyauté fragile
écoutez moi je trouve que ce n'est pas
mal tiré
hélas